if you're totally here the triangle and
you want to find the under okay how
would we do it it is changed well I'm
going to advise you draw the diagram for
yourself and then if you've got two
colors that are different to the ones
you use that'll be really useful to see
one second okay the sign rule each
version of it requires four people
straight there's the piece you want to
find indicated the length and then
there's three other things opposite
angles and then another side with its
opportunity okay so the first thing you
look at is what's the one you want
there it is so which angle does it match
up to it's the obtuse angle in this case
right so I'm going to use one color to
identify opposite angles they need
another side with its opposite angled
right so the other side here is seven
which makes its opposite angle this one
in the corner 45 degrees comedy is a
different color to indicate that so I
don't mix them up once you've identified
that's time and a hot a bit of a
straightforward question is going to
make sure you don't just randomly choose
an angle and match them up properly I'm
going to use this forward side rule
because I want to find a sign I want to
put the sides up here at the top rather
than have to put a paragraph it upside
down I managed to scratch paper here so
I'm going to write x are on sign we're
turning actually I spot a line you for
don't even think you technologies seven
on sine 45 but you go to basically work
for uses anywhere all axes you to make
extra subject is to write seven sign a
hundred and twenty on five point five
that's good yep good area use external
music teeny so final day already
you can use the Sun with a right angle
triangle I'll show you why this
definitely assist in this because the
lovely thing about the triangle is in
what is any trying week on job and in
one angle happens to be nine degrees so
we do just want to be naked you can use
someone's I waited community that
actually are Georgia you could doing
that let me clapping it good seven sign
120 symatry the same as sine sixty isn't
it I think he is really that denominator
sine 45 that's another that's a that's
one one on Richard put that in brackets
so I don't compute my fractions on
factions could you do that can work that
one out
yeah this root two on the bottom here
right could you're dividing by a
fraction that scale is going to pop up
the top so I think that'll be seven root
six one two and in fact that's already
rationalized so I guess you'd leave it
there if you just punch this into your
calculator I'm assuming you get some
weird decimal go ahead and check 76 on
to does it get the give give you the
same value you happy with it okay by the
way what was the definitely got 875
points biochemistry make we put those
it's okay now just before we leave it's
important every time you do any kind of
question where it's possible to sort of
to attend ship right have a look
does the value make sense okay now put
your face down promote I'm going to
teach you how in situations are
triggered option like it can actually do
a logical a bit of a superpower and
check on these you can do more than say
that's seven that's eight point five
seven yeah I'm in the right ballpark
okay you can do better than that
genome panel is going to here see this
45 degrees house opposite seven okay
here's what I want you to do I want you
to put out your arms in front of you and
if you were these two sides okay now if
I'm if you had one arm in front of you
and one arm directly to the side of 90
degrees right so now have a look at that
and in Harbor Thank You 45 okay have you
got 45 ready yeah okay now that's size
let's
to do yeah the site that you're looking
at it off to you is seven centimeters
right so just visualize well actually
you can make a seven centimeter things
platform okay and here's what happens
you want to make that seven centimeters
wide on what you do is naturally you
would widen your arms wouldn't you does
that make sense
and having as this angle get bigger
necessarily the side joining your
fingers right is going to get longer
does that make sense
keep your pressure on them angle gets
bigger side gets longer now have a look
at this do you see if I've gotten six
point five seven I have no reasonable
sinner like ballpark but yeah it looks
like a critic just on the triangle but
it can't be six point five seven it can
see the angle is y dot right so that
lead it necessarily makes a longer sighs
that's why I put a five seven dollar
just like moved about the right ballpark
it actually makes sense that okay now
here's my new triangle except you should
recognize triangle right we're trying
goes bad is this one right with a
crucial difference that we're about to
discover okay so here I've got the
difference under estimate so I'm going
to then I can say oh I know I can use
the sine rule beyond because if you have
a look at the features that you're given
again if you're just like you did before
you start would be unknown you notice
okay
the unknown is a sample chosen by
telephone the other is an angle I can
see the opposite sign and then you
notice other able T on and you have
positive press
cleaner I can use the same okay so let's
kind of go to when you start to on write
out the sign rules like this because
what werewolves top we're going to learn
sign feet up on what the opposite side
when I do fractions on taxes I always
put the one of the factions or votes
from the black
confused want one that's equal to so far
group this looks familiar we were just
working with right I'm going to multiply
across right this guy's going to turn up
on the numerix I already know what
finally five is oh how many things go
kick left
what's the things right seven seven two
great big gone
right what about this are rich chicks on
route to skew recognize that don't you
that's going to give you it looks three
like root three on - okay okay now at
this point this is an exact value image
you don't recognize these next values
you can reach for your calculator and if
you press sine inverse of root three or
two onto your calculator and no
television or remember well enough it
should hand to you sixty degrees then
hold on a second what what just happened
we just worked on this triangle and we
knew what the sides of the angle ones we
tail with 120 but going from this
opposite direction
we got something different a question is
why they want to volunteer a suggestion
there's lots different way to explain it
yeah cool anyone want to offer a
different thoughts on what's going on
today
maybe we'll though okay let me say it
again in case you didn't quite catch it
cuz it's really the crucial point when
you look at this guy in that line there
right just forget about everything else
on the board and imagine that line if I
asked that you sold adequate we've been
doing this since like last week right
you've solved that equation you say okay
ASPCA is positive so much rajasam eight
one and two and of course you expect two
solutions whenever you different like
this you almost certainly be named two
solutions and then you say the first one
conclusion and there's a second quadrant
solution and you accept well you can
have two keys wine remember maybe straw
a quick and dirty one just like it
remember what sign looks like okay
familiar is a shame that right there's
the sign of chest retreat about one
point seven rectory on twos about point
eight point in six weeks I think so if I
draw that
that's one let's just imagine that route
through two and you can see the two
solutions one two so in this case we
have ambiguity Co actually could be
sixty right you can't like do you know
that sometimes interest that I told you
before how I stand up you've got a
longer wider angle here that gives you a
longer size does it still work
over here could I put 60 Inc you can
make a triangle that makes sense in your
chair you're totally can right once
you've got this angle matches to decide
you've got a bigger angle that matches
to them they decide sixty still bigger
than 45 do you agree so sixty degrees is
not the only answer though you can take
or 120 does it still make sense well it
is that I can that's what we had before
okay so either of these two affordable
and if you recall the ambiguous case now
I really to start to work with it but I
won't point out what I said before
remember I said up does it make sense
okay sometimes is other sometimes it
does for instance so right at that
position wrong but suppose down here I
didn't get fifty or hundred twenty
suppose I got to just be given already
supported I got ten degrees or a hundred
and seventy degrees that is first
quadrant angle and a check
illegal both of the solution right
except I know actually one of these
solutions is a done which ones are done
this one he are even though it gives me
a legitimate solution from whatever
tribulation I had right you try and put
this in a triangle and you're in a
little bit of trouble perfect because
you've already got a 45-degree angle
you try to spit some 170 in there and
suddenly you've got two angles adding up
to 216 degrees and I don't know what
that shapes that is but it's not a
triangle because it's not going to fit
in your angle song okay there's one of
the thing you can do which is have a
look sometimes it's this guidance to
done right in this case if you've got a
smaller angle over here
that's not with a smaller side that is
wide enough to run down much because you
wouldn't have any capital a to you
but you've gone look carefully at the
angle you get and not just say I got two
angles could be either you've got to go
back to your triangle remember actually
I'm not just solving this in isolation
I'm solving this in relation to this guy
do the answers make sense sometimes both
do sometimes only one so you have to
look carefully okay